no it's too heavy for me to carry and I
might throw it at some what's up guys
we're talking about fidget spinners
today you know those spinny little
things that are sweeping the nation sure
we know what they are cuz fidget
spinners are a young person's game but
that's why we wanted to hit the streets
of New York City to see what the
grown-ups the adults the older folks
what they think of them or get they even
know what they are let's take a walk
what do you think this is sure it's some
kind of kid toy something you play with
right spinning around on your fingers I
don't know what that is
they are everywhere though I feel like
they're for sale everywhere I go I think
they're spinners there was a note sent
home from my daughter's principal saying
they can't kids can't bring fidgets to
school I had no idea what it was so this
is called a fidget spinner
I've heard of spinners that's all I know
about Pat a month ago was in the
newspaper actually now that you say the
name I have there was a thing on the
radio station last week about it I have
no idea what they do but I've got
granddaughters so I thought I should
check them out so if I handed it to you
how would you think to use it oh I guess
I would go like that I think you'd throw
it and it would spin and go different
directions I have no idea did a stress
reliever I don't know really what you
meant to do but I guess that's it right
that is exactly right you just spin it
like that and do you feel like that it's
calming to you in any way no no no I
would say it's wasting my time nope just
you keep holding in your hands and it
just keeps spinning that's it okay that
works I feel I have to learn how to use
it do you get the appeal of this okay
honestly no why are they so obsessed
with it kind of this
smooth-running thing I don't know
there's something like therapeutic to
just the smoothness I suppose what would
you say to kids who are obsessed with
this making their parents go out and buy
them one well I would rather them spin
this than be on their cell phones I
think it's a scam to get parents money
get onto yo-yos much more fun a lot of
these things that kids do they they're
transient how long do you think this is
gonna last uh probably his lies pet
rocks did to which as we all know pet
rocks did not stand the test of time
just silly overall yeah I think it's
best to get a woman forget your money
people parents like us
[Music]